I want to just have everything I own fit  in one picture you don't want anything  nice I think one of the traps of like  modern humans is like just living a  materialistic life and just chasing [ __ ]  non-stop for what you got robbed right  yeah I did well so my car was worth more  than my house so like I bought that car  and then someone robbed my house and  then stole everything I owned and it was  like because the car wasn't yeah because  they're like oh this car is worth more  than that house sometimes I wake up and  I think oh damn maybe one day I get like  a 911 GT3 or something just buy the GT  do it for a year and then I think you'll  realize it doesn't really matter yeah no  I mean yeah yeah no yeah